I think the Internet is can be very
useful I mean people have websites in
fact I have a website and I'm 59 years
old that must be really stupid it's it's
a huge you know important innovation but
does it have anything to do with what I
do I mean meet Julian Schnabel not
really I'm more like a cave person I'm
actually painting something with my own
hands doesn't go through the airwaves in
invisible speed and end up in somebody's
head it's about you're looking at
something and you're finding something
that's inside of yourself the internet
helps with education making people more
aware of certain things but really you
think you can get anything on the
internet I could think of something that
I could say right now that you couldn't
get on the Internet
I'd like to have a plastic awning from a
butcher shop in the Atlas Mountains in
Morocco when it's rolled up it's red but
where it's been exposed to cover the
window of the butcher shop
the Sun I'd like this the Sun needs to
bleach it so it's ochre it's kind of an
ochre and dirt color and the image of
that will look like the New York skyline
I think it'd be very hard to order one
of those it's those are the kinds of
things you have to go there see them
find them and then get 10 guys to help
you disengage it from the metal
structure that's hanging over that
butcher shop and your kids have to watch
well it's very boring and it's hot out
there as the people fold it up and it
smells like meat but you stick it in
your suitcase and maybe you could get it
back to New York stick it on a stretcher
and make a painting of it put some white
on it write a word on it and then you've
got your art and then somebody can look
at it and see if it means anything to
them you look at what's not generic you
look at something that becomes a
palimpsest some kind of stasis that can
include things that are nameable and
unnameable and these unnameable things
that i mentioned before the things that
I try to put in or that I put into the
movies that's like silence you sense it
sometimes and you think I feel more
alive so as an artist what do I really
do I point and say did you see that
can you see that